well you know both in China in the u.s.
a question I like to ask people it's a
very it's a very simple almost shallow
question but you know well why can't you
cut your energy use in half you know why
can't you reduce your environmental
footprint you know what and then at the
policy level I mean I'm all for
campaigns to tell people to change their
lifestyle but as an economist I think
people are basically good basically
going to respond to incentives so
another way of asking the same question
is why can't we raise the price of
gasoline to five or six dollars per
gallon in the United States you know why
don't we set a tax so that whenever the
world market price goes down the tax
increases to keep the pump price at
about five or six dollars if the world
market price goes up then you can reduce
the tax just tell Americans the price is
going to be five or six dollars per
gallon forever and you should change you
know you should change your purchase of
automobiles and how you use automobiles
and how you heat your home and just you
know I think we can live a good life
with significantly less energy input and
I think for the on the environmental
side energy is the most important issue
but they're there water issues as well
in many developing countries so the more
general question to people is you know
why can't we live you know a very
productive and happy life style but with
just much less environmental impact
you